[Music]
welcome to the Android emulator deep
dive and your hand and this is Frank we
are software engineers from the Android
emulator team so um back in the days in
2015 in the previous Android dev summit
we announced Android emulator 2.0 served
if you remember here is what it looks
like in 2015 and is 2018 now so things
have progressed quite fast and we got a
newer emulator with a newer look so if
you look at the details there are few
differences you might have noticed
firstly there is a frameless skin
suppose in the 2018 emulator which
doesn't have the window frame for you
and gives you a better newer experience
and secondly you might have noticed that
in the expanded panel there is a much
longer feature list which we have new
features such as screen recording and
virtual scene support snapshot and
Google Play Store so I will go over all
those features in this talk one by one
yes from 2015 2018 we have developed
quite a lot of steps in the engine
Realtors and we are mainly focusing on
two areas one is the performance
improvement of the emulator the other is
new features and we are focusing on
improving your day-to-day developing
experience as well as CI server testing
use cases so first things first let's
get into performance the first thing we
want to focus on about performance is
unhybridized the supports so it's just a
little bit background about hypervisors
and the it yard running the Android
emulator at the lowest level you have
your own computer hardware on top of you
you have your operating system and the
highest level there is the emulated
Android OS between the emulated engine
OS and your your operating system there
lies the high processor which translates
the angel severe commands into your
euroversity commands so that test or
Part IV to the CPU acceleration if you
don't have a hypervisor
you can still run the emulator but
everything will go pretty slow and the
emulator becomes super sluggish so in
here is the list of the high process
resupport on English we have a VM and on
Windows and Mac we support hexam with
Intel CPU so unfortunately back in the
days if you are using an AMD CPU on
Windows machine we have no support for
this combination so we got a lot of
requests from AMD users to a support
program
so these 2018 now things progress pretty
fast and obviously we have new
hypothesis of course so firstly we
suppose a newer version of Hexham have
some servant of virtue which is stable
than the previous version and he also
gives you better performance then the
added hybrid hybrid framework support
for Mac users which in most situation is
faster than the hexan on Mac and at last
we support hypervisor framework also
known as hyperbole on Windows which can
emulate an AMD so so finally the
combination of AMD and Windows is
supported and yeah this also gives
docker support alright so if you
use the high-pressure performance the
next thing we want to go into will be
the ATP performance so a little bit
background if you try to push an app
from your computer onto your device when
you are debugging or to deploy you are
going to do this ATP push command which
copy and transfer to F from one entry at
the other so here we are showing the
chart for a TD push time on a physical
device on two different Google Apps the
Google Photos app and Google Santa
tracker app and there are both on
physical devices and you can see what
the first thing was that if you are
using a USB cable and you're pushing the
Google Photos app it takes you
approximately eight seconds if you're
using a USB cable yes these three table
things goes a lot faster and we take you
approximately four seconds so you can
observe similar phenomena when pushing
different apps like the Google Santa
tracker USB cable used in general a lot
faster than USB cable but those are for
physical device so her about the
performance on the emulator so here is a
chart if you do a push on emulator the
Google Photos app takes approximately
0.5 seconds which is a lot faster than
USB 2 or USB 3 and this other chance on
an android audio device and it turns out
that the OS version matters a lot as
well when you are doing the approach so
we college shut on the new newer Android
PI device and if you are working on a
physical device the ADB push is a lot
faster on either USB curiosity and
emulator still gives you very the best
and very constant performance
so again shot if you have between the
app development on twitting emulator you
are not going to have any worries about
either USB cables or Android versions we
have you covered you always get the best
and consistent performance all right the
next topic we are going to cripple and
snapshots so we will be showing demos so
with that less handy Frank and Thank You
Gohan so a top concern of Android studio
users is the time taken to deploy their
app whether it be to a physical device
or emulator and previously people are
used to this workflow where they're
inside studio and they want to deploy
their app and they need to wait for the
emulator to boot up again so we try to
address this in 2017 and in 2018 the
first way we try to address this is
through snapshots we call this quick
boot with quick boot the device state is
completely saved when you take a
snapshot and when you take a snapshot
when you exit the emulator and you
resume from that snapshot when you start
the emulator again so in a sense it's
kind of like sleeping and resuming a
real device and we've also made
improvements in recent emulator Canary
versions to make it even closer to that
so the demo I'm going to show you here
is I have two AVD set up in the AVD
manager one of them is called API 28
we're going to be using quick boot with
that and the second one is called API 28
cold boot and we're going to cold boot
that and so for the benefit people
haven't seen this already I'm gonna cold
boot one of these a VDS you'll see that
it starts out with a black screen it
takes a while to show the Google logo
but with
buuut the Emilia just pops up right here
you'll notice that law cat has already
started up and we can interact with it
immediately just as the cold boot
emulator has just started up alright so
just gonna get rid of the cold boot
annually for now and move on to the next
part a demo so in addition a quick boot
in July of 2018 we've extended a
snapshots feature to be more general
so with quick boot you can only have one
snapshot being saved and loaded at any
one time and that can be useful but
maybe sometimes you want to test
different device configurations
different device states and so forth and
before now you didn't really have a good
way to do that but in the latest
emulator stable version 27 310 which was
released July 2018 we're now giving you
that generic snapshots UI in this
generic snapshots UI you can save and
load snapshots arbitrarily so for
example I can immediately resume one of
these snapshots to stopwatch and running
and a stopwatch is running I can also
edit each one of these snapshots and add
notes
and the description is saved and is also
displayed over here I can also take new
snapshots where this take snapshot
button so these are some examples of
what we've been doing with snapshots in
trying to make your life easier when
you're deploying apps and testing them I
would also like to at this point go over
some improvements we made to the quick
boot mechanism itself in recent emulator
canaries the version of the emulator
running right now is 28 0 15 in the
recent emulator canaries we've tried to
listen to your concerns about of
extremely long saving time for the
emulator when you're closing it now if
you want to save the young later
actually wait let's just set up this
stopwatch again it's saved trust me it
is yes it was saved so we've employed
new technologies like file backing of
the guest RAM in order to speed this
process up in addition we've also added
some console commands that are useful
for CI users when using snapshots one
very common workflow is to reset the
device to a particular previous state
and then run your test in a reset the
device state again to that end we've
added this command called in the in the
console it's called a VD snapshot remap
0 so assuming you're using the default
settings it's like you're Auto saving
the current device state all the time so
right now we're on the second we're at
40 seconds and so the first time you run
this it'll save it around then but the
next time you run it it will very
quickly rewind there so this happens
quite quickly because all the rest of
the end of your UI and all that has
already been set up
it's just a device state that's changing
so you can just keep doing this like
rewinding very quickly and you can be in
any state of the device and just keep
going back to that one state very
quickly with this command another
feature that we've been working on in
recent emulator Canaries is launching
multiple instances of the same AVD so
let me just set this up again okay zero
seconds all right so before when you're
using the emulator if you want to test
multiple different device States and
launch them all at the same time in
parallel your lip options are pretty
limited you first have to create a whole
bunch of a VDS that reflect the
different device settings and launch
them all in parallel or and you couldn't
even start two instances of the same way
VD because you got this error message
saying that the a VD was already in use
well we have a new command for that now
it's called read-only I will show you
the command here okay actually it's
missing but I'll type it again so it is
called - read-only and so when you run
this command the emulator will start but
discard all changes I am starting it in
the background just to make it easy to
start many of them so I've just started
a second one it's actually overlapped on
the first a third one fourth one and so
you have these a VDS that all running
independently but they're off the same a
VD name because I just use API 28 for
each of them and notice here I'm
printing out the FPS and memory stats in
why are some of these only around 200 or
300 megabytes a resident memory well
that goes back to using a file mapping
for the guest Ram
in this case the parts of a guest memory
that they share in common that they have
not modified yet will be shared and will
not occupy proportional setsize a
resident memory or what have you
so it's called copy-on-write
and we hope that this makes your
experience developing apps and testing
them more streamlined thank you now back
to your hunt back to the slides nice
yeah so I think it's kind of obvious to
see but here's our comparison of the
boot times if you are using the creep
with Fisher versus if the other in the
code boot so and in the cooperativity
takes you more than 20 seconds to total
natural safe on our metal per machine as
we are demoing today and on creep wood
and it is usually about one second so
back to it frame for the next demo
mm-hmm yep back to the demo so the next
part starts out with you've also
improved GPU performance of the yum you
later in recent versions and in recent
years we worked a lot to bring OpenGL
es2
support very conformant and to support
OpenGL ES 3 to this end we've created
some benchmark demo apps that showcase
what the emulator is capable of so I'm
just starting this test over here and so
you can run for you like real-time 3d
applications like this that are
competitive with real device performance
but before we go any further I like to
go back to Johan and the slides to go
over another interesting feature
so coming back to this national support
if you remember in 2010 the emulator
like even before emulator 2.0 we have
our crippled feature and natural support
and back in the times the emulator only
supposed Nationals for grantees and CPU
the big missing part here was GP used a
snapshot so this eventually Falls our
users to choose between a hardware GPU
emulation and the Quick Poll tesha if
you choose the hardware GPU emulation
you'll get a pretty nice runtime
performance but your boot time because
of and you need a slow boot if you
choose the crippled feature you put on
will be fast but you have no one hand
hardware GPU support which means the
runtime performance will suffer so
digits in 2010 and people have always a
choice but between the two and it is
2018 now we have better version of
everything including the hardware GPUs
national support this allows our users
to choose both the crippled feature as
well as Harvard Review emulation
simultaneously so if you look at what
was happening behind the scene for this
how well GPUs natural support here is
the emulator reviews stack at the
highest level you got the emulated
pendulous which issued GPU commands at
the lowest level
you got your hardware graphics card
which accept an ethical in GPU commands
in with him then we have the emulator
layer which we call them translator so
the translator will translate
GPU commands from the emulated Android
into your hardware GPU when we are doing
the GPUs national support we put all our
snapshot logic into the channel
little layer such delivers serialized
these own states and dump them into your
natural safe bio so one big question
here was their hardware states which is
eventually a blackboard to the emulator
and different vendors implement it
differently so to save and load hammer
state we use standard Cherokee eyes to
fetch all the hobbyist days from the
from your habilities card into the
trance little layer then the transition
layer will serialize all of them and
write them into your National file in
this way we can save and we cover your
whole emulated hardware GPU States so
that's all right thank you go on now in
this demo I like to demonstrate that the
GPU state is being snapshotted in its
entirety we didn't just do something
special case for Android UI it can
resume 3d apps like this almost
immediately with the snapshot load
feature alright and you can for those of
you don't know already can rotate the
emulator orientation using these rotate
buttons so back to the slides I like to
show a brief presentation alright so I
know that many of you know this already
but for the benefit of people in the
audience who don't know yet we like to
recap on some of the basic ways to use
the command line to launch the emulator
which can include some useful options if
you're running a CI server or otherwise
power user so the emulator resides and
your Android SDK folder Android SDK root
slash emulator and once you're in that
directory you have to give the AVD name
using a dash AVD command-line option
note that this name may differ from
what's displayed and the AVD manager so
if you want to know what the exact
sequence of characters that you need to
input there
you run emulator - list a VDS second how
do you control quick boot sometimes you
don't want to use snapshots or you don't
want to save your changes on exit well
got you covered so the first one
no snapshot load is to perform a cold
boot without attempting to load the
current state that is on the device the
second one quick boot discard changes
the snapshot is good for some CI use
cases and for people who just want the
consistent startup experience and want
to wipe it clean when they're done with
it in this you entered no snapshot save
on the command line and all of the
changes to the snapshot will be
discarded when you exit the emulator
finally if snapshots are just not your
thing you can add no snapshot to the
command line and that will bring the
emulator back to the way it was before
and to recap and the demo I gave earlier
when I was launching multiple instances
of the same a VD well that is the read
only option that option will control
whether you're allowed to run multiple
instances of the same a VD or not and
when you're running in that mode all of
the changes to both the guest virtual
disk and to the snapshot whatever you do
it will be discarded when you exit to
invoke this you would run emulator - a
VD the AVD name followed by - read - -
only and I put an ampersand at the end
you don't have to to launch it in the
background it's just convenient for demo
purposes here alright now I like to also
talk about some of the command-line
options for some of the features that we
have introduced recently to the emulator
in particular screen record screen
record is a feature where you can record
the contents of the emulator to a video
file and then play them back using your
favorite app
this is great for CI user we want to be
able to easily record what's going on
when running tests on our app and to
easily send reproductions of bugs to
stakeholders so the first set of
commands concerns how to start and stop
this we can recording a DBE move screen
record start followed by the path to the
file will start the recording and it is
important that you provide the absolute
path otherwise you might not get it
saved it's a little confusing it's
already working on it the second command
adb EMU screen record stop stops the
recording and is a signal to save the
file so after you're done with that you
can access the file the second one
concerns if you don't really want the
full video recording part you can
instead just take a screen shot in this
use case the console command is screen
record screen shot followed by path to
the directory where you want the
screenshots to be saved now let's go to
the demo where I will demonstrate the
screen recording commands so we're in
the emulator right now and let's let's
try to find a different app just to
record won't we start up the camera
alright so were you so that's going on
and I'm gonna run this so adb a mu ABD
screen record start users qualify it's
my user name documents they have summit
demo WebM so while it's recording let's
just move around and hear a little bit
make something happen and stop the
recording
okay that's weird kind of oh sorry I
accidentally typed a VD there yeah so
let's do another recording all right so
the the video is saved and you can open
it in your favorite web browser okay see
ya there we go so it's a WebM file it
will work in most major browsers second
there's also a UI for recording these
screens it isn't the extended controls
under the screen record tab so in a
screen record it starts out with a
single button start recording so once
we're starting recording we'll move
around a little bit maybe go to recents
swipe the way those apps and stop now
once you're done recording you don't
have to save it to a file you can
reprieve you it directly in the extended
controls UI so there's just a video of
what we just did go to reasons like the
way the apps go back to the home screen
but you can still save it in wherever
you want so let's just save this as demo
to you and that similarly works in the
browser okay so that's one of the
features that we've added in 2017 and
2018 is screen recording to make your CI
use cases better another feature that
we've been doing a lot of work on and
it's pretty exciting is a our core
support now a our core support consists
of a few main components the first one
that you may have seen already is the
virtual scene camera with a virtual
scene camera we render a virtual
environment which is suitable to image
recognition and model placement and AR
apps so I'll demonstrate a few of them
here in the background in Android studio
I've opened the augmented image they are
core sample this is available in scene
form Android SDK from github and what AR
core provides in it it's not just for
the emulator but there's also
integrations in studio as well so for
example there's this scene form plug-in
for Android studio where we can view
models that are met for use in aerocorp
apps in addition we can change all the
material properties we want directly in
studio so this is the lower-left frame
and I might just say lower the red tint
of a bit okay I guess that didn't really
changed a color very much
so I'm gonna change blue to zero as well
so once you save these files the model
should get reloaded and you'll see that
it's mostly pure green now and we can
the workflow we can just edit this model
and deploy it to the device while we
wait I guess right and so in this app we
are looking for images to recognize
another feature that we've added to the
emulator for AR core support is the
ability to load augmented images this is
in the extended controls panel under the
camera tab now we can choose different
posters to appear inside the virtual
scene and I've set this JPEG of the
earth to appear both on a table and the
wall so once you travel inside
scene with this and turn face of wall
we're starting to detect the image and
it shows up there so this shows that we
can if you're in a developer of AR apps
you have this m10 workflow where you can
start in studio and do it all in the
emulator with a virtual scene camera so
that's pretty cool
finally another feature that I would
like to mention that I call out unless
if you haven't seen it before is
improved support for updating GMS core
and Google Play services it is very
important to have developers because
they need to test how the app will
actually run with different versions of
GMS core if you are using a Google Play
Store image in the extended controls
panel there's a tab called Google Play
and inside it there's this button that
shows both your current GMS core version
and a button to update it once you press
update you'll be taken to the Play Store
and be given the option to update it I
happen to have updated already and is
the latest version so it does not give
me a prompt to update here but if a new
version does come out it would say
update I would also like to talk about
the integration of the Play Store D&M
your emulator in general so this can be
useful for app developers who would like
to test their app in more end-to-end
scenarios for example if your app
requires other apps to be installed in
order to work you can download them from
the Play Store directly also you can
look at your app in the marketplace and
see how users are reacting to it right
there and from different device sizes
and form factors and so that includes
the feature demos so back to yon in the
slides all right so here is a summary of
the features we talked about today you
might have noticed there are two
channels of the emulator out there so
the first one is the stable channel
which is the one you know
we get the latest updates from July 2018
and the second channel is the canary
channel which is less stable but he has
other cutting edge features we have in
the emulator and it is released weekly
so feel free to try it out and in the
stable Channel we have this feature this
piece of t-shirts already released
including more hypervisor supports quick
boot feature generis national feature
the page doors and screen recording and
virtual and the AR core and virtual
center supports if you are trying out
the canary channel emulator you have a
few more stuff including the faster clip
with feature as we have shown in today's
demo as well as the multi instance
support and for those of you who are
curious about how to switch the channel
here use a quick instruction in the
Android studio you can turn on your
preference page and in the updates you
have that your channel switch right
there after that you go to the emulator
download page and use your the newer
version available for download so I
believe that concludes our talk so we'll
be qae in the laundry so thanks for
attending thank you
[Applause]
[Music]